Kelly Rowland tells us what she thinks  of Beyonce's lemonade so proud of her  try this again  queen bee was not mincing words serving  up some serious realness in her HBO  special a new album lemonade with strong  themes of infidelity and anger can't you  see there's no other man above you what  a wicked way to treat the gutter to ET  was with Beyonce's longtime friend and  fellow Destiny's Child bandmate Kelly  Rowland on Sunday at Safe Kids Day in LA  where the singer gushed over B's new  emotional record  she's just so transparent beautiful  music I'm very proud of her and it's  that transparency that has the Beehive  buzzing like crazy especially over this  lyric with the girl fans speculate Becky  could be fashion designer Rachel Roy who  addressed the controversy on Twitter  writing quote I respect love marriages  families and strength what shouldn't be  tolerated by anyone no matter what is  bullying of any kind